[THEME MUSIC]
FLINT WATERS: Well, hello there.
I want to thank everybody
for making it to Next 17
and for braving
through the long day
to come in here
for this session.
This is the closest
in my athletic career
I've ever come to
batting clean-up,
to be in here at
the end of the day,
so thanks so much for making it.
I'm Flint Waters.
I was the former CIO for
the State of Wyoming.
I'm now with Google.
It's a long journey
that gets there,
and I'll talk a
little bit about it.
But we're going to talk quite
a bit over the next hour
about the methods
we went through
and the pain we suffered
and all the things that
came about being the very
first state to go Google.
And to kind of capitalize on
the sentiment behind the need
to drive quality of
life improvements
for the citizens
of Wyoming, I want
to step back to
the very beginning
of my journey with
Google as a partner,
and it started, oh, 2002, 2003.
At the time, I was the lead
of the Wyoming Internet Crimes
Against Children task force,
and the United States Attorney
for the District of
Wyoming was Matt Mead.
And what I did at that time
is I spent a lot of time
on the internet looking for
predators, folks that targeted
children, and when
I very first started
doing those types
of operations, I
noticed that I had the
potential, through technology,
to very dramatically impact
the lives of our citizens.
And after the first couple
of undercover arrests--
I used to pose as a little
girl on the internet.
I'm going to let you shake
that image off for a moment.
But after the first
couple of arrests,
I found quite a few
indicators of guys
that were physically
abusing little bitty kids,
and I started doing
some research on how
we could find them, because
the big trend at that time
was to hang out in chat rooms
and get these emotionally
crippled guys that would show
up to meet a 13-year-old girl.
And in the course of working
in those types of cases,
I found guys that were
targeting infants.
They were targeting toddlers,
and I wanted to catch them.
And so in conjunction with
the US Attorney's Office,
I developed some
algorithms that would
let us find these guys that
were hands-on abusers, that
were hurting kids,
through the guilt cycle
that they demonstrated
on the public internet.
And I could identify, based
on their traffic patterns,
the things they were doing
in clear public view,
who was likely a
hands-on abuser of kids.
And I took that to Matt
Mead, the US attorney,
and I made the
case that I thought
we could actually
leverage technology
to rescue those kids.
And the US attorney is
a political appointee,
presidential appointee,
and he had aspirations
of a political
career, and I didn't
think my odds were
good of convincing him
that, through these algorithms,
I could successfully
catch these bad guys.
I keep moving
forward here, sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing.
But Matt was always
the kind of guy
that he measured things based
on is it the right thing to do,
and so he said let's go out.
Let's do this.
Let's try it out and see
if we can get a rescue.
Our very first search
warrant, we went out.
We got a rescue.
We got a child that
was being abused,
and we started doing
more and more of these.
And what I found was that all
the jurisdictions around me
were having the same
issues, but there
was a lot-- they were
very tentative to work
internet undercover
operations because it
was difficult, from the
beginning of the investigation,
to see if they
were in your yard.
The internet really
challenged law enforcement,
and it challenged a lot
of the laws early on,
and so we used Google Earth
to give law enforcement
a graphical representation
of where the offenders were
in their jurisdiction
and then prioritize
the likelihood of which
ones were hands on abusers.
Before long, it was being
used in all 50 states.
We shared this with
all those around us.
We then started sharing
it internationally.
I taught it at Interpol,
and I taught at Cairo
and Malta and Australia.
And it ended up
going global, and we
rescued thousands
and thousands of kids
on the back of that technology.
And over the course of that, it
really punctuated the sentence
that government could have
a strong impact on quality
of life by appropriately
engaging technology.
And so I was always
favorable to Google
because the way they allowed
me to leverage Google Earth--
we didn't have any money.
We had no funding for
this initiative-- allowed
me to go out and make
those things happen.
Well, the US
Attorney Matt Mead--
I retired from law
enforcement 2008.
When Matt Mead ran
and then became
governor of the
State of Wyoming,
he asked me to come into
the state as the CIO,
and I got the opportunity
to serve under the mission
that he wanted us to figure out
how to do for all of government
what we had done for kids.
So the tasking was empower the
business needer, the needs,
to be able to innovate
in the way that you did.
That was the challenge he
gave me walking in the door.
The prior CIO,
Bob von Wolffradt,
had just signed the contract
to be the first state
to go Google, so they were
starting the early adopters
the week that I came in as CIO.
And I want to talk a
little bit about it
because it was interesting,
the day I walked in.
I walk in.
I walk into the administrative
assistant for the CIO,
and I say, OK, here's
what I'm going to need.
I need a MacBook.
I need an iPhone.
I'm going to need--
she said, no, you
can't have that.
I said, well, why not?
Well, this is-- we use
Windows 7 and a BlackBerry.
And I said, OK,
well, I understand
that, except I need a
MacBook, and I want an iPhone.
And I want-- she said, no,
that hasn't been approved,
and I said, all right,
who has to approve it?
She said the CIO.
I said this is me.
You could hear the hush
fall over the building
because I was one of
those that used a Mac,
and in government, that's
not-- that's startling.
And I think a lot of
it was because there
was such a strong vested
interest in the expertise we
already had.
There was this
commitment and belief
in the investment in
ourselves for the things
we knew how to run,
which is sometimes
contrary to this
concept of innovation,
and that's what led me
to the doorstep of what
Wyoming took on moving forward.
Now, here's my first key for
you that I would recommend.
If you're a state, and you're
looking to move to the cloud,
you're looking to
innovate, I would recommend
that you get what I had, which
is a very tech-aware governor,
someone heavily committed to
tech as a quality of life issue
because it makes a huge
difference to helping
us get started.
But I want to speak to
this, but it's not going
to be about where we've been.
That's it.
That was the history, as
why I reached that point,
and it got me to the point where
we had all of these rescues,
so if I completely
blew this, they
would go, oh, that's all right.
Get out of here.
At least you did something
good in your life.
I'd be OK.
I was able to take a
little bit of risk.
But it was far more about
where we were going,
and I say this because I saw
RFPs coming across my desk that
were formatted about
wanting new technology,
and included in the RFP was
all the limitation tying it
to where we had been.
It was all the language
that restricted it
to how we had
always done things,
and I was struck
by the fact that we
want you to help us
innovate, but we really
don't want to change anything.
That leads you to a
rather difficult decision,
and it really empowers a
CIO to make a bold shift.
And that's what we
tried to take on.
One thing that I learned
early on in this,
there's two things
that people hate--
change and the way things are.
So I was positioned in a point
that, no matter what I did,
we were going to struggle
with perceptions and outcomes.
And so many of the folks
that I was working with,
that were advising me,
again, were heavily
invested in the status
quo, and they did not
recognize that the status
quo has to be defended.
If you wish to believe
it's the way to keep going,
you need to demonstrate
why, and they soon
learned that the
worst excuse they
could give coming into my
office was because we've always
done it that way,
because in tech we've
come to understand that the
way we've always done it,
by design, is wrong,
because we're moving.
We're shifting.
Even to the point that,
in many of our agencies,
every challenge was
met by a server.
We want you to work on
sex offender registry.
I must buy a server.
And this was not
a virtual machine.
This was sticking in a rack.
Now, early on, these
were not even in racks.
These were desktop units
set in hallways of agencies.
We were completely
decentralized,
so almost every agency
had their own IT team.
They had their own
stacks they built to.
They might be in a data
center, or their data center
might be a closet,
might be a hallway.
It was fascinating.
We had one of our departments,
Department of Health,
had their own
little data center.
And the first time
I went into it,
there was sheets of plastic
hanging from the roof,
taped together, because
the roof leaked,
and they wanted to route the
water away from the computers
because they're--
that's what we were--
I say this because we
were so far behind.
There's a couple
of folks in here
that are hiding their head.
I'm not going to point you out.
It was an interesting
point for us to take on,
but it was also an
excellent opportunity
to engage for a big win
for the State of Wyoming.
As we moved to Google,
we made it a point--
and this is something
that Google doesn't really
speak about a lot, that I think
is a message that's lacking.
And that is it is this
massive and amazing ecosystem.
It's not just G Suite.
It's not just cloud.
The fact is there's so much
there that is interconnected,
that is capable of expansion
and leveraging components
to benefit.
I don't believe anyone else
has this same combination,
because when you look
at it, from Android,
we've got all the
mobile capabilities.
We've got the full
productivity suite.
We've got unlimited storage.
We've got massive
database engines
we can tie in to App Engine,
containers, all the things
that we can build against.
It was a gift.
For me, as a new
CIO, it was a gift.
Now, I get it, that a CIO--
especially in government, the
average tenure for a government
state CIO is 28 months.
They're flipping these
guys like hotcakes,
which means you're really
up there taking a bullet.
I felt, a lot of the time I
would get up in the morning
before I went to work,
concerned that today
might be the day that we had
a major breach on a system
I haven't been able to
get to the cloud yet,
and I was going to step in front
of a round for the governor.
There was a lot of what we
did, but as we moved through,
we got some really
amazing changes
that we didn't anticipate,
and I didn't plan very well.
Now, this session is
designed so that you
can come up and ask
questions, and here's a chance
to get me on recording.
And you can ask the how,
you can ask the why,
what we ran into as we were
building these things out,
and I will be extremely
candid with you.
The only thing I won't
do is cast aspersion
on another vendor.
That's not Google's way.
It was my way six months
ago, but it's not today.
We really started capturing
and propagating ideas
at the speed of
thought, and I say
that because it's really a big
deal to a lot of workflows.
Google was born in the cloud, so
they've known that from birth.
Now, states are a
little different,
and a lot of companies are
a little bit different.
If you hold that the Lord built
the heavens and earth in six
days, you have to accept he
had no legacy data to weigh him
down.
We had a lot to try
and pick-- it's OK
if you pretend to laugh.
I pretend to be funny.
There's a lot of challenge
there in bringing up
all these archaic systems that
the states are so heavily tied
to.
We went through and
replaced 15 email systems,
different directories.
We reduced our email
admins from 13 to two.
Now, we serve an enterprise
of 10,000 executive branch
employees, and we also deployed
solutions for Wyoming schools.
So we put out 100,000 license--
100,000 user license
of Google for Education
and offered it to
any school district
that wanted to go Google.
And we called it Wyo for Life,
and we did this in conjunction
with what we were rolling
out for state government.
So we were managing
both with two admins.
But this empowered us to
completely change the budget
quagmire, to completely
shift how we do business
because, in state
government, the budget prep
cycle to get your dollars
was about 24 months long.
And then there was six
months on the front
of that for your
business case, to get it
through governance
approval and then start
the legislative process.
Well, can you imagine
putting a 30-month lead time
on your agile IT
response to a problem?
That's what we faced.
We had hundreds of
physical servers.
We had two major data
centers on the state campus,
and when I walked in the door,
the president of the senate
was fully prepared to build
us a $40 million data center.
We were going to build
out an IT facility
very much like the
University of Wyoming did.
Wyoming University had
a beautiful data center.
Of course, theirs is a little
different mission than ours.
And I had the
privilege, if you want
to call it that, of going
in front of the legislature
and saying, I don't
think it's a good idea.
Yeah, I'd have a
great corner office.
I'd have a beautiful
view, and I'd
be sitting up here in this
single point of failure.
And it's not what I felt Wyoming
needed for the long game.
So instead we took $16
million, and we built out
100-S gigabit IPv6 backbone
throughout the entire state.
Instead of building our own data
center, we moved to the cloud,
and we built up backbone.
So now, there's towns
in Sheridan, Wyoming,
little bitty beautiful little
town, 7000, 8,000 people.
I should know this.
I used to live there.
There's two vendors you
can get a 100-gig internet
from in that little
town because instead
of investing in
our own facility,
we invested in a
backbone that reinforced
the broadband providers
throughout Wyoming
and lifted everyone.
We went from dead last for
broadband capacity for schools,
for education--
we were like five
kilobits per second
per student, peak utilization--
to first, all the way to first.
And the way we did that was by
getting out of the data center
business.
I mean, how arrogant
of me to think
that I could manage the
cooling and the power
and the physical plant and the
security for our physical data
centers better
than Google could?
And so I didn't
even bother trying.
And you ask the
question, what prompts
you to make that decision?
Well, I asked them to
bring me the certifications
of our physical data centers.
I have those here.
There was nothing.
We didn't go through and
have those certifications.
We were not--
I wouldn't say we
weren't compliant.
But we weren't
externally validated.
We did have audits on certain
types of data content,
but we were still running
everything physical.
One of the other
big opportunities
that we picked up from
disrupting that quagmire was we
moved from buying physical
servers and that budget cycle
and Capex to Opex.
Because as we
moved to the cloud,
everything shifted to a
contracted negotiation
with Google or our
other partners.
Now, Google wasn't the only
cloud partner that I built on.
It wasn't the only
one that I engaged.
It made sense for me to
go out and try and do
a diverse approach,
diversify my cloud portfolio.
Remember what I said
at the beginning
about I will not speak
ill of anyone else?
So I won't tell you
how that project went.
I'll just tell you with Google,
it went really, really well.
A couple other things that
we picked up early on,
we dramatically reduced
our VPN deployments
because we pushed
so much offsite.
This was quite a lift
because prior to this,
almost every state employee
had a VPN connection.
They could get into
the campus from home.
They were able to beachhead
malware on their home computer
and then deliver it
directly into our core.
It was a phenomenal design.
Didn't work as well
as we had thought.
We were able to get
out of that business.
We replaced buying servers
and started buying services.
And we were able to
close our data centers.
Now, that's unheard of.
We closed our
physical data centers.
And I would love to
claim that this was
brilliant foresight on my part.
It was not.
It made sense to prepare
ourselves for cloud.
And I was all in.
I had moved our agency
entirely into Google.
We had no drive shares,
had no drive letters.
We had no SharePoint instances.
Everything was sitting on
Google's cloud for our file
services, which meant I could
function anytime, anywhere,
from any device.
And then, this happened.
So I don't have a pointer here.
But just above and to
the right of the crane
there, see the large hole in
the side of that building?
That's my primary data center.
The legislature
decided that they
were going to approve the
remodel of the capitol
and the adjoining building,
and I had six months
once the funding was released to
vacate my primary data center.
Now, this is government.
We take six months to talk
about what we might do.
It was a pretty big move.
Now, by then, Wyoming IT folks
had become such an amazing--
well, they were
an amazing group--
but they had shifted to an
off-premise dependency, which
made it really amazing
how quickly they
were able to make this
push, and shift and vacate
that data center.
And they did it.
And it was very cool.
Now, this was my primary.
This was my good data center
that we closed out of.
And I want to speak a little
bit about that, because I didn't
know quite how brilliant the
IT staff were that I inherited
as I came into the state.
Because I was always
under the impression
that they were pretty
heavily risk-averse.
And as I started
looking into it,
they had very good
reason to be risk-averse.
They had not really been
free to innovate and break.
The concept of fail early
wasn't really introduced.
And so I had some
difficulties getting
them to take those chances,
to take a leap of faith.
So what I started doing is
every meeting that I would walk
into with the staff, at the
beginning of the meeting,
I would write a one and
a big asterisk behind it.
It's from my law
enforcement days.
And then, I explained
to them, look,
I'm asking you to take a chance.
I'm asking you to invent.
I'm asking you to take risk.
And at the end of
the day, there's
only one ass to risk here.
And it's mine.
If it blows up, it's on me.
You take the chance,
and I will back you.
Once they tested that a little
bit and a little bit more,
I soon became amazed at
how they could invent.
They just hadn't been turned
loose to do that before.
They really did
some amazing things.
Now, I mentioned before this
was my primary data center.
I also had a secondary
backup data center.
But the backup data
center was a little old.
We were in an old
junior high school.
The IT offices were an
old junior high school.
And the data center
was in the old gym,
which had a wood floor, which
is an interesting choice
for a data center, wood
being not as necessarily
safe for where we were
building out our equipment.
That was my backup.
And the generator
that ran it, we
were on an EPA
waiver that allowed
us to turn it on to test it.
It was so out of date
we couldn't start it
until we got the waiver.
So we knew it was
going to go away.
And we were preparing
to have it replaced.
I tell you that because
of this picture.
I don't know if you know
this, I'm not an electric guy.
I do know that they explained
to me that generators
have a certain amount of
magic smoke inside them
that makes them able to deliver
the power we need if we lose
connectivity to the city.
Well, that's our generator.
And that's all the magic
smoke escaping out of it.
It burned up, seized
up the diesel.
I mean, seized tight.
This was right in
the middle of us
moving out of the
primary data center.
Now, normally, if you are
dependent on two data centers,
this is going to be a pretty
impactful moment in your CIO
career.
We were really, really fortunate
because we had built our help
ticket system in App Engine.
So we had already moved
it completely off premise.
We had built out
all of our core IT
onto the Google side for
the enterprise agency.
So we didn't actually lose any
service time as this went out.
As we moved forward, we
finally got to the point
where we no longer had
on-premise data centers.
The only thing left
there, now, there's
a mainframe for the
Department of Transportation.
I put glass in it.
And I make money on the tickets.
I bring people in and show them.
And I'm not picking
on mainframe--
it's great technology--
but all the people
that run it are gone.
It was really, I had
a guy hidden in Idaho
in the mountains that was
there to help me bail out
if we had any issues.
That sounds like--
it's not a joke.
I actually had a
guy hidden in Idaho.
If Tony Young is here,
he's not going to be happy
that I gave that up.
Tony, are you out there?
No?
OK.
All right.
What Google did for us, it
really became a catalyst
for cultural change.
And we reinvented
how we delivered IT.
But we had to learn a couple
of pretty tough lessons
to make this succeed.
We moved to a more agile
business management approach,
and we changed the
employee empowerment
to invest back in folks.
And this is one of my
change management ideas
to point out for you.
Many of the folks
that were around me
were quite concerned that if we
went towards a no-ops mindset,
I wasn't going to
need them anymore.
This was job threatening.
Now, I can accept that it
was expertise threatening
because it required that
they learn new skill sets,
or expand on their skill sets.
But there's a belief
a lot of times
when you start this
engagement that it is also
going to be job threatening.
And it took a lot of effort
to engage those folks
and win them over.
We started a very aggressive
employee training program.
We started pushing folks to
learn cybersecurity roles.
We started pushing to
expand on their skill set.
By the time we got
fully into this process,
our folks ended up with far
more impressive resumes.
They were far more adept
at doing what we did.
And we finally got out of
having folks that ran cables.
We got out of folks that
had to crawl under rocks
and troubleshoot equipment.
We really minimized
how that was,
but it's not an easy shift.
And one of the things that I
would say in engaging that,
find your malcontents
and engage them.
And I loved my malcontents.
Because folks who are not
happy with how things are,
if given the right
tools, are the folks
that can make some of the
most amazing improvements.
George Bernard Shaw talked about
how the reasonable man complies
to fit his world and
the unreasonable man
demands that his world
change to fit him.
I totally butchered the
quote, but so all change,
all progress is based
on unreasonable men.
Well, there's something
to be said for that.
I found the folks that did
not like how things were
and empowered and equipped
them to try and help
make that change.
And it was a pretty
big difference.
Because those are
the same folks that
can find amazing ways to
stop you from doing it,
the same folks that could
find reasons not to.
And I really had to
wrap my head around what
it would take to get
those teams focused
on what we wanted to build.
I'll talk a little bit
about what that entailed.
We got rid of our storage--
our drive storage--
and pushed all of that
to the cloud behind
filer devices.
We moved all of our
physical data center
off and into a public
data center with the cloud
on the back end to expand it,
and anything that we could
go straight cloud, we did.
This was a pretty massive
shift for government.
But it was also a massive
shift in expectations
for the types of folks we
were bringing in the door.
Because a lot of the teams
that I was bringing in
were millennials that had
been using this technology
to succeed.
They were accustomed to it.
My son-- my son's
in high school--
he comes home from school.
He walks into his room.
Byooo.
All the lights dim down
while he powers in everything
that he's got in his backpack.
He jumps online.
He jumps into a Hangout.
He's with six of his buddies.
And they're doing their work.
They're busting out slide decks.
They're doing sheets.
He's in the robotics
club, so they're
designing the next
iteration of their robots.
He expects that
type of capability.
The worst thing I could do to
him, bringing him in the door,
is handing him--
AUDIENCE: Something else.
FLINT WATERS: Something else.
Thank you.
Thank you for-- you could
see where I was looking.
I was just going to
go ahead and jump.
Giving those folks what they
are accustomed to succeed
was a big win.
And it also helped
the expectation
for the delivery of knowledge.
Because we were
accustomed to workflows
where you would
capture the ideas,
you would capture the principles
in a physical document,
you would send it out to
seven or eight people,
you would wait for their
input to come back,
you would reconcile
the differences,
and you would do it again.
At best, you were capturing
one frame of mind a day.
And we shifted that so that
we would be able to capture it
in real time.
Probably, you've seen
some of the demos,
or if you're accustomed
to the tools,
you've seen the folks
jumping and doing
all the simultaneous authoring
and all the pieces that
came together.
Very powerful shift.
And Google is
accustomed to that.
We were not.
We had to reinvent how we did.
We actually tackled workflows.
I tried to convince
folks to look
at every workflow they engaged
and disassemble it and reinvent
it.
And we'll talk a
little bit more.
This was my office.
Originally, I had this
big battleship of a desk.
And it had an $18,000 compressed
digital video unit on it
that hadn't been
used in a long time.
It was like a Yugo
sitting there.
And folks would come in
and sit in front of it.
And I got rid of all of that.
And we worked on the round.
And we took GVCs--
Chromebox for Meetings--
Chromecasts, and we put up
large screens and white boards
everywhere.
We closed half of
our meeting rooms
and put these devices
in the hallways.
And we started using Scrums.
We use Scrum, of course,
for Agile development.
But I liked the approach.
So I started using it for
business management, as well.
We would pull into the meeting
to solve a particular business
issue.
And somebody would throw
10 minutes on the timer.
And we would work
through the solution
and build out the answer.
It was quite enabling
in giving us--
yes, sir.
Would you please go
to the mic for me?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
FLINT WATERS: And if
anyone has questions,
just step right up because
I'm happy to take them
as we're moving along here.
AUDIENCE: I hope you
still have the lightsaber.
That's all.
FLINT WATERS: Oh, yes.
Well, yeah.
The lightsaber is a standard.
I brought that when
I came to Google.
My team gave me that
as we were changing.
That's basic nerd lore there.
We got rid of--
we actually got out of
the phone business too.
There was so much that Google
didn't tell me I could do.
And this empowerment
was massive.
A good example, Governor
Mead and his wife
would go to the Middle East
and provide Thanksgiving dinner
to our guard troops that
were deployed overseas,
the Wyoming guard units,
except that it coincided
when he needed to do
the annual budget press
conference, the formal
budget press conference that
had always been done--
the way they always did it--
in the formal conference room
in the governor's office.
So he went ahead and went.
We set up a screen in the
formal conference room.
Someone sat in front of him at
an airport in the Middle East
with a Nexus 7, and we did a
Hangout live for his budget
press conference.
He looked the press in the eye.
He took their questions.
He joked and laughed with them.
He announced he was
going to run again.
He really leveraged
this technology
as a force multiplier.
I saved over a million
dollars a year just
on the dedicated video
equipment that I no longer had
to buy on the backs of what
I got as part of G Suite.
I saved over $500,000
a year on the denial
of service protection because
I moved the state's website
to Google Sites.
I moved a lot of what we were
doing up onto the Cloud side.
And it gave us quite
a bit of power.
We streamed the governor's
State of the State address
from inside the
legislative chamber
as a YouTube live event.
When he did his large
energy proposal and release,
that was done as
a Hangout On Air,
and citizens could
take questions.
They could jump in,
take questions back
to the governor's office, and
ask about what we were doing.
That was a huge transparency
of government leveraged
by this technology
that we put in
so that we could have
Mail and Calendar.
And this was so much about
where I had made mistakes,
because I did not anticipate
the scale with which this
could change what we did once
I empowered the malcontents.
And please, when I say
that, it's somewhat joking,
but it is endearing for me
because I'm one of those folks.
I'm a disruptor.
I like to break
stuff and reinvent.
I did have a lot of agencies
that I had to win over.
And so I'm going to share
this little bit with you.
And you can make fun
of me if you'd like.
This is a bit of a weakness
of mine, but I'm from Wyoming,
and we have a bucking horse
on our license plates.
It is a cowboy culture.
And I had agencies that I had
to engage to convince them
why they should throw out
how they did everything
and reinvent.
And so, this is
what I came up with.
Sometimes you have
to get off the horse.
And the premise was, if
you're trying to win over
the brand inspectors,
or the livestock board,
or the Department
of Agriculture,
me explaining the power
of machine learning
and data analytics
isn't necessarily
going to convince them that
this is a worthy journey.
So what I did is I went
in and I met when I said,
OK, let's assume that it's 1885.
And you're moving
your herd from El Paso
to the railhead in Cheyenne.
All right.
Everybody is with me.
Now, if it takes you 30
days and the rancher says,
I want you to get
it there in 28 days,
you can put the
spurs to the horse,
and you can get
there in 28 days.
But if the rancher
says, I want him there
in three days, what
do you have to do?
I put it on the screen.
You have to get off the horse.
You have to reinvent
how you do business.
That's how you explain
moonshot thinking
to Department of Agriculture.
I say this premise because
it's really important
to empower the business
leads to help explain how
you justify exponential
increase in capability
versus incremental.
How do you do
exponential improvement?
You have to reinvent
how you go about it.
And with that in mind, we
started running grassroots
training where anyone in
the state could attend,
any of the state
employees could attend.
And I would go in and
just talk about how
to tear down your
current workflow,
your perception of
how business was
done, so that I could get you to
ride Google's innovation curve.
Because in the legacy mindset,
we started building solutions
on a physical
server that started
to decay the moment I
put it into production.
We had $30 million of
investment into an application
that was tied to a specific
version of the database engine.
And over the 20
years it was expected
to run, halfway through that,
that database engine quit
getting patched.
It wasn't getting
security updates.
And yet, we still had critical
government information
in there.
So I had to convince
them that it
was time to start
building on the top
of an upwardly mobile framework
and give them that flexibility
that even if we
didn't get funding
to enhance it next
year, App Engine
was continually enhanced,
made even more secure,
optimized by Google.
So our investment
continued to rise
in functionality and
capability because it
was riding that curve.
I really wanted to
position Wyoming
so that when it was
time to do analytics,
when we could do
machine learning,
our data was secure, positioned
well, and we could operate.
I did not realize when I
did it that we were also
going to free up
enough budget that we
could pay for the innovation.
This was the dirty
little secret.
We freed up far more
than we spent on Google.
Far more.
I moved systems that
would have cost me
$600,000 to build
on to App Engine,
and I paid for the monthly
consumption with a credit card.
The next thing I
would ask of them
is to think about how
much mobile has impacted
your personal life and theirs.
If you think right
now, how much different
is home now because
of those devices?
And would the citizens
feel like the product
we deliver to them is
equally as impactful?
And it clearly wasn't.
We weren't keeping up.
We couldn't do it.
So this was another
capability that I
had to convince these
folks to rethink, reinvent,
and reengage.
Now, there are a lot
of areas in government
where we had clients built to
leverage the software that we
didn't have the funding to
rebuild from the ground up.
But we wanted to
make it mobile aware.
We wanted to make it
deliverable to citizens.
So we built a
synchronization engine
that would scan a
SQL Server, replicate
the schema in Google's cloud,
and then synchronize the data
one way upwards, which
allowed me to continue
to work on premise--
or in our offsite data center--
against the products
I could afford
that were already in place.
But I could build modern, mobile
apps that could leverage it
for the citizens.
So it was kind of a half step
to start modernizing how we
were deploying those solutions.
And that was something that
we, as we moved forward,
found that to be
immensely beneficial.
Because it also pulled all
that citizen activity off
of our network and
carried it upwards.
One of the other pieces that
was a difficult delivery,
and we did finally
get there, is I
needed to get across to folks
that tangible results are
about getting wisdom and
recognition into the mind
of your target audience.
And I say that because
so much of what we had
was built on the premise
of the printed page.
The tangible outcome, the
final result, was printed page.
Now, I won't ask you to raise
your hand, but how many of you
have workflows today
that the first step of it
is to start
formatting a document
to capture the information that
is going to be in the printed
format?
I mean, that's just how we've
thought for a long time.
And yet, it's really
not relevant anymore.
Because so much
of this, if I want
to make sure I can get
into the wisdom before you,
I need to make it present
here, not in print.
When I very first
started and they
got me my first set
of business cards,
I had a fax number on them.
This was 2011.
That was a little sad, actually.
All right.
Here's my challenge.
If you are engaging
in this process, one
of the things I would ask
to consider of your folks,
we have traditionally
designed our workflows
based on our perception of the
capabilities of the technology.
Now, that's potentially flawed,
because very few of us--
now I'm surrounded by a lot of
folks that are brilliant about
this, but in government,
very few of us fully knew all
of the capabilities
of the technology--
and so we were designing
from a crippled version
of what the potential
outcomes would be.
Rather, I would offer
that you challenge it
from your perfect
world scenario.
In other words, invent
what your perfect world
would look like without
regard to the technology.
Once that's done, then engage
the tech to rise to your need.
That shifts from being change
adverse to change expectant.
It moves it to
where you now want
to see the enhancements
that come out
of an agile, capable
company like Google.
And this is where
they really shine.
This allowed us to reinvent
how we started to build.
And most of the
folks, once you can
engage them to
find this premise,
they can invent a perfect
world that the tech
isn't rising to yet.
It's getting closer
and getting closer.
But now, as new
updates come along,
they're more
excited to see them.
And that's a win.
That positions us well as you
move from this legacy, build it
and it's decaying, to
build it on a rising,
continually improving
innovation curve.
And those changes are
around every corner.
It helps leverage that
expectation of what
they're going to get next.
Now, there are a couple of
things I wish I'd known.
About a year ago, I
realized that we had really
disrupted the IT business
model for the state of Wyoming.
And my folks were
doing amazing things.
They were going far
beyond what I dreamed.
They were doing far
better than I, by myself,
would have figured out.
And I found myself--
my deputy CIO was spending a
lot of time just keeping me
from being out in the hallway
terrorizing the villagers.
And they were going on
and doing great things.
And so, I knew I needed
to move on because I
was a disruptor, right?
I like to break things.
And they were really doing well.
So I asked the
governor for permission
to pursue a career with Google.
The governor's a great guy.
And we had a lot of
conversation about it.
And he gave me his blessing.
And so, I separated myself
from all business activity
related to Google.
And I started pursuing to
come to Google because I heard
that they were going to be doing
some new, impressive things
that could help
governments do more,
serve more, rescue kids, prevent
fires, change how government
deploys services.
And I wanted to be a part of it.
And that's what led
me to go after Google.
Now, I am a Googler.
In September, I left the state.
And I got on with Google.
And now, I'm in the Professional
Services Organization.
So I'm part of the
team that now companies
can contract to come in and
give them an inside view of what
Google can do, give them
that trusted partner
to help them succeed.
I so wish I'd had that.
And once I went
through the onboarding,
I learned about Spanner.
Oh, my god.
I would have killed
to have that year ago.
That would have been
a huge game-changer.
I mean, even just Cloud storage.
Had I known that I could
have redirected all my backup
solutions to cloud storage
and then airline storage,
I was charging like
$0.34 a gig for backup.
And I could have pushed
that-- and it was on tape.
It was on a tape library that
you had to wait four hours
to load the tapes.
I could have pushed that
over, you know, what?
7/10 of a penny?
And it was available to
access in milliseconds.
I could have bought it back.
Gosh, I wish I'd
have known that.
It would have been
very, very cool.
There's a long list.
And you're probably
seeing them here.
It is an amazing company.
And one of the things that
I learned once I got in here
is how far they go in
measuring their success,
now our success, based on the
success of their customers.
And I was not used to that as
a CIO for the state of Wyoming.
I had vendors that came in and
told me all kinds of things.
But when things broke, I
wasn't necessarily getting
that same love.
And I've seen how
those things work now.
It's quite a little
bit different.
I mean, you look at BigQuery.
You look at just
moving DR to Nearline
would have been massive for me.
So many things I wish
I could have done.
And there have been
a couple of states
that have done some
pretty impressive things,
some cities have done
really impressive things.
Nicky's going to come in from
SADA and talk for a moment.
You want to come up for me?
Nicky is going to
give an example of--
please, go up to the mic if
you've got a question before we
transition.
And then, whichever one.
AUDIENCE: Just
quick, two minutes.
What did you do with
the ERP HCM workloads?
FLINT WATERS: So what's the
percentage of the ERP workloads
that are failing right now?
If you don't have a really,
really good partner,
there's an awful
lot of risk there.
The areas that were
within our control,
we tried to go back and
reinvent and develop solutions
with partners that
were cloud-aware
to deploy solutions.
That's as far as I
can take that answer
and not talk about
another vendor.
Is that fair?
One of the things
that we also did do--
I do want to share this--
as we built out on App Engine
and moved to no-ops deployment
that leveraged Google's
cloud where I no longer had
to worry about patching
OSes, I no longer had
to worry about
patching databases,
I could just build
agile solutions,
all those solutions that
we built in there, we open
sourced.
Our help ticket system,
our e-procurement system,
our credentialing system
was all built so that we
could give it to another state.
We could hand it over.
Because Wyoming, we don't
compete with Colorado.
It's not like if we
have better numbers,
we're going to buy them, right?
We shared everything with them.
And then, they
can share with us.
We can share with
the other states
that have had the good
vision to move to Google.
And that continues-- that will
help build that repository
where we can leverage that cloud
for all of us for the better.
I'll go and then we'll
do questions afterwards?
NICKY PARSEGHIAN: Yes.
Sounds good.
Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Nicky Parseghian.
I'm with SADA Systems.
There you go.
Thank you.
I'm with SADA Systems.
We're one of the premier
partners over here with Google.
We specialize in G Suites,
Google Cloud Platform,
and also, Google Maps.
Today, what I
wanted to talk about
is one of our counties over
here, Douglas County in Omaha,
Nebraska.
I want to talk a
little bit about what
they did in their use case.
To give you a little
bit of background
without going into too much
details, Douglas County,
Nebraska, so Douglas County
Technology Commission, DOTComm,
they migrated to
G Suites in 2013.
I'm not going to go into
the detail as to why,
or the background, or the RFPs,
which, as Flint mentioned,
RFPs can be very long.
What I want to hone in is
more of the afterwards.
Douglas County, about 5,000
employees, 70 departments,
they support the city and the
county, so all the branches,
ranging from city hall
to the county library
to the county clerk's
office, all of them,
70 total, they're
supporting them.
From a technology
standpoint, when
we're talking about
empowering people
and empowering IT, what
we want to come out of
is not a set of things that
we're prescribing to them.
Because, as Flint
mentioned, you're
used to doing
things your own way.
So if we are talking
about RFPs, we've
been doing emails like that.
And this is exactly,
I'm taking things here,
I'm putting you over there,
and I'm done with the day.
When you're presented
with new challenges,
traditionally you're
looking at a board,
and you're checking boxes.
Does that solution has this?
Does he have that?
You're looking to
find and purchase
solutions that are going to
be feeding your use case.
You don't really look--
I do that every
day, to be honest.
I think I'm a big offender
amongst the entire room
over here.
But usually we don't look
at what we have right now,
which is a big mistake.
With that said,
however, Douglas County
over here, what
happened in early 2016
is that the ACLU of
Nebraska essentially
published a research
that really instilled
some changes across the
state and the counties
within the state.
Without going into details,
what they found out
was if you deprive
children of human contact
and interactions, so in
the corrections office,
in the corrections
department, essentially,
if somebody is
misbehaving, you're
going to put them in isolation,
just like with the adults.
But if you deprive
them of human contact
for more than four
hours consecutively,
it turns out that it
has some dire effects
both on the physical side
and on the psychological side
for those children.
So the state wanted to make a
change right away, of course,
and make sure that all the
counties and all the correction
officers, correction locations,
were able to provide the best
care for the children.
Douglas County volunteered
to be one of the pioneers
to build that
platform and report.
As you can imagine, the
state is given a mandate
and you're ending
up in a room where
you have a lot of people
trying to figure out
how do we do things?
How do we track?
And how do we make sure
that those children are
being reached every four hours?
That's the business requirement.
What they did was
very innovative.
They looked at what we have.
They didn't have budget.
That thing happened
in January of 2016.
Budgets are closed.
There's nothing.
There's no funding available.
You can't buy a
solution anymore.
So they looked at what they had.
And they went to the whiteboard.
They have a lovely
conference room over there.
I've been there
quite a few times.
They just whiteboarded
the business process.
They made it very
simple, which is,
I'm going over there whenever
somebody is in isolation.
I got to go and check
on a few things,
make sure that first, they
are all right, and also,
can they go back into the common
area with the other children?
To do so, you have
a few requirements.
Of course, you have a few
boxes that you have to tick.
And that's what they did.
They built very simple processes
with tools that they had.
Everybody has mobile devices.
They went, themselves, on G
Suite with our help in 2013.
So we knew, we all
knew, that they
had Gmail and mobile phones.
As a result, what we
did was we leveraged
Google Drive, Google
Forms as an input.
We didn't have to
design any interfaces.
design anything.
All we had to do is,
what are the questions?
Focus on the content.
Don't focus on the form.
To Flint's point,
many people focus
on the interfaces and the design
before focusing on the content.
Forget about all that.
Trust that Google is going to
give you a platform for that.
So they built forms,
and all that information
fed into a few sheets,
into a few Google Sheets.
And what they had
to do from there
is literally just
monitor that information
and build some metrics,
some graphs, some reports,
to present that to the county,
and to the state, sorry.
With our help, they were
able to do from stage zero
to 100% in just a few months.
It was very impressive.
And in fact, they were at
like 95% when we went there.
We literally helped them getting
the most out of the platform
by leveraging Google Sheets
and Google Apps Scripts.
Sorry.
What we did is we've
broken down the process
to business requirements,
kept it simple,
kept it straightforward.
What do you need to do
to accomplish your task?
And then, transform out of it.
With that said, I
think this example
is a very good transformational
example of an organization that
essentially uses the tools
that are at their disposal.
I urge you, and I invite
you, to look at the Suites.
What you have right now,
many of you, just like us,
moved to G Suites
primarily for email.
At first, you didn't want
to manage your emails.
You didn't want to have a server
somewhere, no matter which
brand or manufacturer.
You just wanted
to get rid of it.
So G Suite was your
point of contact.
And with it, you gained a lot of
tools, a lot of functionality,
a lot of beef.
Whether your users adopted it
or was not really your concern.
Because you had
your ROI already.
Nowadays, though, if you're
switching and looking
at the overall value of
the Google Platform--
and I hope that you're going
to learn a lot of things
throughout those three days--
you can have a lot of very
interesting optimization
that you can do, whether you're
using G Suites over here,
or Flint mentioned App Engine,
Compute Engine, Dataflow,
BigQuery, I think.
You have a lot of these.
I can't even name all of them.
There's literally, I think,
60 or 70 of these services.
Just focus on what you need,
use exactly what you want,
and then iterate out of it.
Constantly innovate and iterate
so that you can stay on top.
Right?
Google is going to
iterate on their product.
I was sitting in a conversation,
in a session this morning,
Google Sheets, in
2006, apparently
could not handle more
than 1,000 cells of data.
So imagine back then if you had
to build this workflow on this,
it would have faced
quite a few limitations.
But sure enough, without
changing a lot of things,
Google just innovated
the back end
and made it a wonderful
product as it is today.
Trust that the platform is going
to get even better and better
without having to have any
negative impact, upgrade,
platform, or anything like that.
And just build your
workflows, day in, day out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]